hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to vanish now a lot of
you guys have been saying that I need to
get back to this though I finally
decided I could if you don't know what
this is or if you haven't seen my other
place because of it this is the one game
that really really reaches me it it's
quite quite perturbing / / true being I
don't know it's scary so I'm gonna play
it but this time I promised myself that
the next time I visited this game I
would beat it so that is my objective
right now I am going to beat it I know
this game pretty well I'm I think anyway
so I know this game pretty well I know
what it needs to be done I don't need to
sprint because I don't need to attract
any attention i I have a good
understanding of it now if I could just
grow some balls and finish the damn game
I could don't want to entertain you guys
anyway sorry for the late upload today I
just got back from the Cincinnati
Children's Hospital um they were
interviewing me or talking to me about
certain things that we can try to do to
get more attention out and apparently I
did not know this what is that what is
that what is that I recognize that oh is
that a thing or a rat anyway they didn't
tell you guys new I think I told you
that the Cincinnati Children's Hospital
got most improved but with that award
and this I did not know um came an extra
$20,000 donation from a company that I'm
not exactly sure what it is but that's
awesome which it raised our total
donated to like $75,000 they attributed
it to me I mean it went to the hospital
but I mean they they said that I did it
because I was the one that kind of
pushed them up over the top and really
drove that and by me I mean you guys
it's really all about you guys they were
selling they were thanking me about it
kept reiterating that it was you guys so
sincerely thank you guys so much for uh
helping to support that great cause but
anyway that's besides the point of what
I'm doing right now I'm trying to beat
this ding dong damn game anyway so
there's not much to say that I haven't
said already it's really well made
graphics degrade blah blah blah
that's how it's gonna be I got my volume
like way cranked up I always get my
volume up when I play these games and if
you forgot it's all randomly generated
and it changes when you play the game
okay that's nothing I got a I got to
remember what sounds are real and what
sounds are not so it really doesn't
matter which way you go it's all oh here
we go
look the first time I fell in my rail
Mazdas I remember that's done it's been
a while since I played this game so I
don't really recall the sounds anymore
access ladder and grab a replacement
okay now I don't remember are these from
the creatures are they from I'm a little
on edge okay and the volume is like way
way loud so how about you cool your jets
and stop laughing at me and you try to
play the kid I kind of worked it up in
my mind that I was like what you me
someone whispering over there but
someone whispering over okay all right
by the no away you and probably knows my
hair is very messed up I don't know what
happened don't look psychic
I know what I want to look like yeah I
kind of worked it up it huh don't
through puberty I kind of worked it up
in my head that it may not have been as
bad as I remember but it just as bad oh
I don't know what it is about this game
okay all right okay all right that's how
it's gonna be okay
seriously I said that every time I play
this I'm like I don't know what it is
about this game that gets me but it gets
me
Levi me
yeah I didn't want to panic and run this
gate I was gonna attract the attentive
what what why okay what happened no what
happened I think I took a wrong turn
until remember all these damn gates and
where the hell is a giant holes in the
wall coming from oh I don't know
yeah anyway I was talking about my hair
yeah I got a I'm it's getting long I'm
kind of growing it out sorta maybe I
don't know but it got it was real sad
like you know my normal fauxhawk it
usually stands up by itself but it just
kind of fell over
very sad first world problems with
markiplier he's trying to distract
himself from playing this game I said I
was gonna beat it and that's what I'm
gonna do I promise you guys okay
alright cool alright cool made it to
here wherever here is helpful helpful I
don't even know why these glow sticks
would help me it all changes I haven't
seen a single monster yet but oh god
damn it I swear to God Jamie's going
with over here
get out gonna get out no no no back it
Blake the beginning
I don't think I can fight wait I don't
think it can find me in these dirt holes
I saw it just walked past while I was
tagging one out I think it's safe in
here BSA tank
my name is Hank my name's ah Hank its
mark Lulu Lulu hey soon
so what we're doing Oh doing wide arc ok
late Thank You light thank you you
beautiful light oh oh ok still that was
that if the generator is bloated Oh your
nose is in the darkness you're not it
I can't feed your feet in front of my
face I'm gonna die I'm not that's just
it I'm gonna die this is the end of me
I don't even how to use a glow stick me
me me me me me me me me me me me me
hey Mindy oh look another place
Hank Hank listen I saw it I saw it I
think it was listening for me just
charged at me I ran just run
don't let it hear you what can hear you
when you run can it okay alright
I'm okay oh I'm out of run juice I am so
Bo dragon yeah yeah yeah still there
gone gone leave me alone
boom ha ha I did it to learn I'm gonna
say my run jeez for what I need it what
is that I don't know this different new
I don't know what happened to start
right behind me I knew who's gonna get
high Oh base Dave hmm hmm oh it's gonna
be oh it's gonna get me good monochrome
but uh I'm still loud what am i doing
clip-clopping with tap dancing shoes ok
oh they changed things
see what I mean when they change things
they what here we go
aha now I got light now I can beat you
bastards I got you by the shorter your
scruffy your balls
don't ask what that means cuz I don't
even know I don't even know what I'm
saying right now I'm just that lovin
why what is that what is that what's
happening to me
I don't see you a monster let's do it
okay Tom's generator what hell nobody in
this maze okay I'm going north from the
generator I think but our north/south I
don't know these don't make any they
have sense cuz it would change why would
it help me what is with the wonkiness
why am I going insane Luna why I'm
cutting shut up I know you're not real
are you real buddy you're not gonna give
okay I thought I saw maybe they maybe
they're tricking me by putting like
shadows and shapes in front of me I
wouldn't be surprised
this game is capital grade-a [ __ ]
with me Oh about that am I gonna do
about that good good okay
I really don't know where I'm going uh
hey look if v if I'm falling this Maps I
should be able to get to the gym if I
get to the pumps by taking a left up
here baby
who in through the nose out through the
mouth calms you down makes you heart
rate flow I'm still in the wonky vision
what make another I don't know how many
night legs I have why is this fair it's
just sitting in the middle of the damn
road or stores or whatever you want to
call this I don't know but I'm probably
gonna die holy don't make any noise much
noise either that make some noise but oh
no oh no this wasn't here you need to
find the key piece it hope it changed
I'm gonna no you give it oh give it yeah
what are they gonna do
I want to get to the end but I can't I'm
trading I just gotta find a keep did I
have I ever found the keys that I do not
know I don't know if I've ever ever
found the keys okay I'm gonna hurry
because apparently the longer I stay
down here the more crazy I get yeah I
literally don't think I've made it any
farther than finding two generator room
maybe I've found the pump room maybe but
I don't know Oh get with it whatever I'm
fine I'm fine
uh Hank blue smooth did you pissed it's
a Stewart don't do that it's a steward
of course it smells of piss it's a it
doesn't matter where I go I've learned
this or maybe it does or maybe it
doesn't I don't know I don't think I'm
ever gonna win this game
Oana is that I never have to play these
okay what is that I understand this
before what is this we mean it's the
four corners but what does it mean rue
it yes grid I haven't even found oh god
damn it okay I was gonna say if there
was one behind me I was gonna be very
upset okay oh sorry I'm trying to adjust
the volume as I go I don't blow out a
microphone Hey oh god another four
corners or four whatever I don't know
that what is called we're corners of
douchiness Lily yeah okay here's a hole
in the ground that means I can hide in
there if I need to but do I need to I
probably do but not just right now
see I'm getting more well not me but I
mean the character is getting more
oh my shop oh I found some whoa okay
I stopped okay this is different this is
the pump room pumping Oh elmo's walk
right into that ha ha maybe if I want to
end my journey here maybe I could lure
one in there so I could fall down I
might be stung yep circles circles
circles uh the Potter Pump Rooms right
behind me but I don't think it's gonna
stay there ah the generator room cool
wait a minute can I find like the keys
in here or something no just more glue
the keys you got the keys uh what got
really quiet
oh yeah
Looch another good thing ah I got the
key oh I thought I saw something oh my
god oh yeah I did oh it's for not
overloading the microphone Oh
keep running I know he's buying me I
know he doesn't gonna give with it
easily
I'm making noise see it's different
different Stanford just let me find the
damn gate a little bit damn game so I
never have to play it again oh don't run
oh I got a headache
Oh oh good one in front of me I'm oh
come on just let me find that door let
me find that door Oh doesn't think I
like provide any light anyway it wasn't
even it was just mildly comforting
little comfort in my bleak and meager
existence please please I'm begging you
I keep thinking I see the outline of a
thing up against the wall but no James
II meenie miney mo
I don't give a [ __ ] I go not being so
weird man stop doing that
ah oh just evyi run now it's gonna be
chasing me Raj
oh the deal let's dickbag oh my god damn
it
screw your butt alright by me I gotta
get moving okay okay look it would be
nice to have like a map even though it
wouldn't make a bit of difference
give me some give me the damn some
rather give me the damn something I I
know I owe ya that's gracious goodness
gravy I don't know where I'm gonna go
now
oh if there's one in front of me I'm so
bone I'm hoping that the game isn't a
giant dick and always finds one at time
otherwise I'm royally effed in the a one
give it to me come on give me some give
me some give me a little bit give me a
little bit of something anything
I've noticed that
no no no no no no no no no no no no I
won
RoR senior dickbag came from but I won
that okay I had it in the bag I was
gonna win I won technicality I
everything to me to the end I did win
did it i won and my in my heart of
hearts I know that victory was mine was
that the guy that was chasing me before
because I was Nicolas ridiculous
absolutely ridiculous
why why right nope nope nope nope
ain't gonna happen ain't gonna happen
I'm done another two months I'll pick it
up again I'm done fine got it
fine joy make you happy are you happy
now living in constant misery and
suffering it guys are enjoying this
aren't you guys are enjoying it Oh cry
the first thing I find it going yes yes
alright
I'm doing great my hair just went wild
though I'm just gonna leave it that way
my hair has a mind of its own either
whatever I'm not happy about this not
happy about this guys I had that I had
it it was right there in front of my
face
I had it I wasn't even running you know
I wasn't like attracting attention it's
just like the guy came at me I thought I
was fine I rounded a corner I was
running away I looked behind that's
probably why maybe I was the end of the
game no I don't know
I haven't looked up a walkthrough or
anything oh no that's the end of the
game maybe you're not supposed to escape
maybe that's what it's gonna be a mess
anon there was a thing on the map that
says ladder I'm pretty sure he's got to
be away very grumbled right now I'm very
like it did he just disappear get me
online
did you just banner I think he just
vanished a pretty sure nah it ain't
natural all right
yeah I saw something there I start I
start something there on the right did
you guys see that cuz I saw it it's like
an arm of that with no projects go crazy
I'm very paranoid right now and I hey
there's a hole in the ground I don't
need to go in there I don't think unless
I'm running away from a guy that's what
I need those holds for but they never
come up
oh thank goodness okay this is good
found one which means I found the glow
sticks and now I can go find the
generator I'll get the keys and then I'm
home free right I'm going back through
your mother probably I I'm not I'm a
little more self aware of the phases
that I make during these playthroughs
just because I'm Moses time when I'm
doing someone's really poor or poor yeah
but that's yeh-yeh oh please let me win
we're the key where are the keys give me
the key
I don't know why I haven't real
remembered that happens whenever I leave
the generator room that always happens
it's always a big fourth um this close
dick doesn't do jack doodlee [ __ ] I see
you know that's not you those are
portable
I swear this is close dick it does
nothing the goggles did Lou nothing guys
stop
oh is that a hole all right so if I need
to run away I know where to go
hello mr. radio bus
I haven't even gotten to the distressed
papers on the wall oh [ __ ] huh god damn
it came to the steam where's the hole
where's the hole where's the holy hole
what's a hangover huh all darkness come
in come in you're in okay all right
saving grace I'm gonna win it guys I'm
gonna win it you know other people have
commented that I've met in real life
that I play games with and stuff I can
get really loud like that's why I have
so much trouble with my mic cuz I have
such a large range of just extreme
loudness to screams oh my loud is very
loud and when I yell I literally have no
control it's
belted out okay eeny meeny miny moe it's
backed by the toe please don't kill me
go home you he's the Pope
get another close to hello again oh oh
oh oh I got a headache from yelling
someone oh go away go away
how much going your mother in the after
you're ugly
you'll never amount to anything your day
was that I do spy some smelly someone
farted oh no it's just your face so
stinky and bad I did my best insult I
could he's very very forward or else I
I shook him to his core he's very
emotionally dabbling since I can't hit
him or anything he's crippled
emotionally for life no good good I'm
not sorry
I've no idea where I'm going I think I'm
just going in a big circle okay I really
I'm like okay there we go all right so I
think just where I came in
Oh Oh No either way gotta find the gate
gotta find the gate gotta find the gate
with no monster not on my tail gotta
find the gate gotta find the gay game of
the gate
gimme the gate oh yeah in the hole again
give me the whole damn thing damn thing
damn dings what am I gonna do now
I'm just crawling around the hole that's
my life Oh was my life I think I'll make
it my wife huh
little bit with my back epidemic I
seriously got a headache I'm like oh man
my heart's bound in a million beats per
minute my hands are shaking I'm doing
good doing good I feel good I feel good
about things and stuff I can win this I
know I can just get me to the damn gate
and let me go home
mmm-hmm
this is new I'm gonna go right this time
cuz left has not worked for me left
seems to be very bad ah God ding damn
[ __ ] I'm not even I'm not going in the
hole screw holes holes bad I'm just ah
ah
I can't do it again I can't do it again
guys I can't do it again I'm done
my head hurts I want to yell anymore
can't help it
No Oh lakyn I'll pick this up at another
dump I tried I tried the game did not
want me to win every time I turn out of
a hole
always always always always old anyway
thank you all so much for watching I am
sincerely sorry I couldn't beat it but I
just can't do this anymore
though thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation more
reviews than I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video goodness
bye bye
whoa
you
none
Oh from